[Music]
hi i'm rob siegel lecturer management at
the stanford graduate school of business
i teach six different courses at the gsb
but today we're going to talk about the
key takeaways from one of them the
industrialist dilemma
what's different about the industrialist
dilemma is that the combination
of physical and digital is completely
different than anything that's happened
before
and it's increasing the speed with which
markets
are able to change and it also enables
new companies to come into markets that
previously would not have been able to
and you can study every industry to see
how the combination of hardware and
software
digital and physical are being impacted
by these technological
and business model changes one of the
things we've learned in studying the
industrialist dilemma
is that neither incumbents nor
disruptors are necessarily preordained
to win in the market
disruptors have a blank sheet of paper
they can think with a clean slate about
how they're going to meet customer needs
but they often don't have the domain
knowledge of what it takes to be
successful in a particular market
incumbents often have deep balance
sheets but they need to move more
quickly and build skill sets
and competencies that maybe they haven't
had previously in their organization
in a world where every product is
connected companies need to keep in mind
two things
number one they need to develop the
capabilities to write the software to
communicate with the customers
and then how to manage it on an ongoing
basis to listen to the conversations
with customers to understand
how customers are using their products
and to think about how they can
constantly be improving their products
to delight customers and thinking about
customer outcomes
at the same time organizations need to
understand that the entire ecosystem
might be jealous of that ongoing
conversation and relationship
between maybe a company that
manufactures something and the end user
and people in a channel might want to be
a part of that data stream
going back and forth
in a world where digital and physical
are combining to create
massive disruption across industries
somebody's going to end up being the
underdog and somebody's going to be on
their heels
being an underdog can actually be very
liberating in some ways
when you're on your heels you have
nothing to lose and you have a license
to try new things and be very creative
you can look at ways
in which headwinds can actually become
tailwinds
that can actually propel you forward so
as change in a technology
a change in an industry could actually
be an opportunity
for a company to catapult itself to do
business in a new way
an example of a company that turned a
headwind into a tailwind
is the north american electronics
retailer best buy
eight years ago their product was being
commoditized everybody was buying
televisions
and telephones online and just trying to
get the lowest price
but as all of these products became
increasingly connected to the internet
their level of complexity went up what
best buy figured out is they could be
the best
service retailer not just selling the
box themselves
but making sure the customers knew how
to connect them to the networks and to
each other
to deliver a better customer experience
companies that innovate on both new
technologies and new business models
end up becoming the winners long term a
great example is align technologies
the people who make the clear invisalign
teeth straightening tool
the technology behind the clear plastic
aligners was very very difficult it is
very difficult to manufacture
but what they did really well is they
also increased their channels selling
not only through orthodontists but
through dentists
which very much expanded the market and
allowed adults to start using the
product and not just teenagers
what we found is that having business
model innovation
and technological innovation was a real
force multiplier
and doing only one of these was
necessary but not sufficient for
long-term success
as companies from the technology
industry moving to things like health
care
and financial services they start
getting into areas where governments
increasingly regulates these areas in
addition it starts to get to national
industrial policy
leaders of companies for the next
several decades are going to have to be
very conversant in how to work with and
collaborate with governments
all over the world and know how to be
successful in a world that's
increasingly complex
hi i'm rob i'm the short ball guy in
front of the class i have a linebacker's
mindset and i used to carry around books
that were this thick when i was in high
school